[Musique]
bonsoir à tous excellente année 2010 9
je suis ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos votre
magazine consacré à l'actualité
économique du territoire tout de suite
le sommaire c'est le rendez vous
international des acteurs de
l'innovation technologique le cs de las
vegas plus de 400 entreprises françaises
ont fait le déplacement parmi elles des
sociétés basée à saint quentin en
yvelines dont sky one portal des
créations d'entreprises en hausse en
2010 8 de plus en plus de personnes
décident de se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat choisir le statut
juridique les financements et le
business man les plus pertinents
découvert des accompagnements proposés
par le ce qu'est le ski club avec jean
marc bodiot ti à la fin de cette édition
retour sur l'actualité économique dans
le département et notamment le lancement
d'yveline business club pour ouvrir ce
magazine direction le consumer
electronics show 2010 9 de las vegas
avec une entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines sky one portal c'est sa
quatrième participation durant cette
édition
reportage saint quentin en yvelines
représentés dans les allées du cles2 las
vegas 2010 9 la start-up sky one portal
a rencontré près de 200 contacts
qualifiés lors de cet événement 50 %
dans le secteur de la santé des
potentiels partenaires des états unis de
la corée du sud ou de l'inde
beaucoup de surprises parce que les
personnes qui sont venues sur le stand
des responsables de maisons de retraite
ou d'hôpitaux et qu'ils disent a
effectivement ce type de produit on ne
pensait pas que ça pourrait exister que
ce soit présentée ici est donc ce fait
des contacts
plus qu intéressant je pense à ces
secteurs la solution présentée cette
année c'est mover un produit destiné au
secteur de la santé
il a été conçu par sky one portal dans
la pépinière d'entreprises promo paul à
montigny le bretonneux
je vais utiliser cet écran tactile pour
manipuler l'expérience changer la
vitesse de déplacement ajouter des
ballons des obstacles et le forcer à
effectuer certains mouvements pour
éviter les obstacles ou attraper les
ballons l'objectif c'est de forcer le
patient à effectuer certains mouvements
générés un conflit sensorielle entre ce
qu'il voit et ce qu'il ressent
physiquement
cette solution a été développée pour un
kinésithérapeute du pôle vertige
équilibre de montigny le bretonneux
déstabiliser le patient en faisant
disparaître la route accélérée ou
reculées des manipulations pour générer
un conflit sensorielle le but de celle
de les forcer à ne plus s'appuyer sur
l'or sur le visuel mais un peu plus sur
leur oreille interne ou la somme est
saisie c'est à dire le corps dans
l'espace créé en 2014 sky one portal est
spécialisée dans les solutions à usage
immersive lors du cs 2018 à las vegas la
société a créé un partenariat avec
créative works pour sa plateforme de jeu
immersive aujourd'hui créative works
construit nos produits pour le marché
états unis nord amérique australie
nouvelle-zélande et on a aussi un
distributeur sur le japon qu'à marcher
aussi assez spécifique mais c'est vrai
que c'est aussi des territoires où le
notre solution divertissement
fonctionnant très bien nouer des
partenariats pour la distribution des
produits l'objectif de la participation
au cs avec à la clé une activité
dynamique
depuis sa création la start-up réalise
entre 50 et 100 % de croissance
[Musique]
près de 330 entreprises ont vu le jour
sur saint quentin en yvelines en 2018
un chiffre en hausse par rapport à 2010
est pour parler de ce sujet nous sommes
au laboratoire de la création
d'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines au ski cube avec jean marc
bodiot t-bonds soir bonsoir
alors vous êtes responsable de la
relation entreprise au ski cubes alors
la création d'entreprise est elle un
phénomène économique important pour
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un phénomène qui se développe
d'année en année c'est un sujet qui
intéresse évidemment nos créateurs
d'entreprise qui trouve notamment sur
notre territoire et plus précisément à
ce qui fut de toutes les ressources
nécessaires pour créer faciliter leur
création d'entreprise alors concrètement
sûrement dans les détails comment vous
les accompagnez au quotidien
nous travaillons sur plusieurs méthodes
évidemment nous avons comme je voulais
dire un réseau de partenaires des
spécialistes de l'accompagnement donc
nous pouvons balayer l'ensemble des
différentes phases du projet de création
d'entreprise avec une mythologie
adéquation à des vis du projet la
rentabilité notamment de l'activité
on sollicite notamment un réseau de
partenaires experts comptables avocats
spécialistes de la propriété
industrielle spécialiste aussi de
l'innovation qui permet à nos créateurs
futurs dirigeants nos futures pépites du
territoire de se développer le plus
facilement possible
alors qui sont ces personnes qui
viennent vous rencontrez quel est le
profil type du créateur d'entreprise
saint quentinois le profil type
une quarantaine d'années majoritairement
masculins 35 % d'entrepreneuriat au
féminin donc c'est un chiffre en
constante évolution notamment
et puis avec une volonté aussi de créer
des activités liées aux services aux
entreprises
avec un territoire qui nous environ
16000 établissements sur saint quentin
or parmi les créateurs d'entreprise sur
51 à 36% qui sont demandeurs d'emploi
c'est un commentaire par rapport à ce
chiffre passe est une façon pour les
demandeurs d'emploi de créer leur propre
emploi
ça permet aussi de bénéficier de
différentes aides liées au pôle emploi
d'un accompagnement aussi renforcé puis
une volonté d'indépendance et
d'autonomie sur leurs projets jean marc
barr jeudi maintenant on va découvrir
deux entreprises créées en 2018 il
s'agit de la voie du luthier à
guyancourt et de lgc à montigny le
bretonneux
regardez
c'est une enceinte audio particulière
conçu entre guyancourt et la vendée en
2016 christophe duquenne passionnés de
musique électronique et spécialiste en
informatique et marc lucas luthier on
monte les premiers prototypes
aujourd'hui ils ont créé leur société la
voie du luthier avec deux produits londe
et la pyramide
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il fallait des
enceintes amplificateur classique pour
entendre un instrument électronique
aujourd'hui en fait en offre une caisse
de résonance naturel en bois comme une
caisse de guitare ou une classe de piano
pour entendre le son de l'instrument
électronique déjà si on compare à une
enceinte habituelle
l'enceinte est très très directif sans
voile sont dans une seule direction
alors que quand vous écoutez un violon
une guitare ou un piano
le son est vraiment diffusé donc là on
va voir cet effet de diffusion la
vibration se propage sur toute cette
table d'harmonie qui va faire vibrer de
l'air et l'air va venir jusqu'à nos
oreilles c'est comme ça qu'on va
entendre le son de l'accord d' amplifier
ou le sont les créateurs qui va être
amplifié une création fin novembre 2018
accompagné par bg e et initiatives saint
quentin en yvelines avec un prêt
d'honneur de 25000 euros complétée par
un financement participatif sur
kickstarter de 89 milles euros 100
commandes ont déjà été effectués et des
participations aux salons de musique
électronique comme le superbus de berlin
où le nam de los angeles
autre situation avec lg s'est
spécialisée dans le génie climatique
un projet en cours actuellement la
fourniture et la mise en réseau des
machines de ventilation à la fort pas de
guyancourt nous notre travail en fait
ces deux d'intégrer en fait dans cette
machine un coffret électrique une
régulation un système d'automates et
réaliser le programme pour pouvoir
automatisé cette machine est la rampe
fonctionnelle est le gc a été créée en
août 2010 8,7 holding regroupe deux
sociétés déjà existantes
une entreprise spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie de l'automatisme et une
autre en lien avec les services du génie
climatique
une création d'une nouvelle société
nécessaire pour son développement
la demande du marché commençait à
changer et il fallait en fait avoir une
offre
beaucoup plus globale la holding a
apporté en fait des partenariats avec
des usines dont basés à l'étranger une
usine en turquie une usine en république
tchèque
des nouveaux partenariats d'automatismes
comme avec des majors comme comme
siemens ou un partenaire en chine
on s'est autofinancé par nos propres
moyens on sait on sait après autofinancé
par les projets et les marges des
projets donc du coup quelque chose qui
se développe qui pourrait se développer
en cinq ans il se développe en disant
avec neuf employés et un chiffre
d'affaires de 1,5 million d'euros
cette entreprise cible le marché
national deux tiers de ces clients sont
situés en ile-de-france alors on voit
ici deux exemples d'entreprises qui ont
été créées en 2018 dont une que vous
avez accompagné financièrement c'est la
voie du luthier déjà une réaction sur
cette activité qui est dans l'innovation
une activité passionnante notamment qui
a trait novation et musique avec un
système de vibrations musicales tout à
fait étonnante et qui notamment à
bénéficier donc d'un prêt par initiative
saint quentin et qui a bénéficié aussi
de d'une campagne kickstarter d'une
levée de fonds notamment le quasiment 90
mille euros à ce jour alors l'autre
entreprise c est le gc on voit que c'est
une holding en fait finalement c'est une
société pour gérer deux autres
entreprises qui étaient déjà existantes
est ce que c'est ça aussi la richesse du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est d'avoir des entreprises déjà
existantes qui se réunissent pour encore
avancé rayonner à la fois sur le
territoire mais aussi au niveau
international
tout à fait c'est un facteur de
croissance indéniable ça permet à ces
entreprises d'être plus forts de
répondre à des notamment des appels à
projets des marchés de façon beaucoup
plus consistante et surtout de
pérenniser et développer l'emploi dans
leur entreprise
un dernier sujet sur la création
d'entreprise vous l'avez vous avez
commencé à l'aborder avec initiative
saint quentin en yvelines c'est bien sûr
le financement différents choix se
proposa un créateur d'entreprise soit il
s'autofinance à partir de fonds propres
c'est à dire qu'il ne fait pas appel à
d'autres partenaires financiers pour
financer sa création ou sinon il peut
passer aussi par des partenaires
financiers donc comme les banques
comment vous vous saisissez de ce sujet
pour accompagner parce que c'est souvent
le nerf de la guerre
ah c'est un sujet passionnant au
quotidien avec nos entrepreneurs
le fanny financement nous avons ce
réseau de partenaires bancaires sur le
territoire de saint quentin qui nous
accompagne sur les montages de projets
tant sur la partie création la reprise
et la transmission d'entreprise est
aussi un sujet très important et le
développement des entreprises un réseau
banquière qui est aujourd'hui un jacques
plus de 4 millions d'euros sur nos
entreprises saint-quentinoise dans le
cadre du financement initiative 50 ans
jean marc barr je dis merci d'avoir
décrypter ce sujet de la création
d'entreprise
passons tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref dans les yvelines
la famille du ski cube s'agrandit cinq
nouvelles sociétés ont intégré
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines
une inauguration vendredi 18 janvier par
mieux foot connect l'application paris
maintenions youbi experts élaborent
lives in business club c'est le nom
d'une nouvelle association d'entreprises
installées dans le département
elle a été lancée jeudi 17 janvier et
vise à rassembler des chefs d'entreprise
partage d'expériences négociations
d'affaires et participation à des
déjeuners débats avec des invités du
monde politique sportif ou économique
ce lancement l'occasion de connaître
l'état d'esprit de certains dirigeants
d'entreprises yvelinois concernant la
conjoncture économique de 2019
je rends compte énormément
l'entrepreneur aujourd'hui qui sont sur
des croissances 2019 cèdre est une année
à peu près correct normalement il n'ya
pas de trop grosses inquiétudes et on
est sur les mêmes bases de l'année
dernière des commerces indépendants ou
petites structures dont que c'est très
très compliqué
par contre pme là je sais tu pas avouer
ouvertement très directement mais on
sent beaucoup plus d'optimisme
une possibilité d'investir et le
sentiment moire est elle vraiment très
concrète des changes avec les patrons de
pme notamment dans les yvelines c'est
une difficulté à trouver les bonnes
personnes
le groupe apave a inauguré jeudi 10
janvier une nouvelle agence à guyancourt
cette entreprise spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement de ses clients face aux
risques techniques humains et
environnementaux dans différents
secteurs d'activité cette nouvelle
agence une expérimentation de sa
nouvelle organisation du travail
un espace décloisonné entre les
différentes activités se situent
liancourtois réalisé près de 7,6
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en 2010 8 avec un objectif de dépasser
les 8 millions c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
le mois prochain au salon tech innove à
paris avec les acteurs de l'innovation
saint quentinois à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]